[Music]
let's go to suzanne out in spokane hey
what's up suzanne
hi there
hi there how's it going i just love that
it rhymes suzanne and spokane it just
made me happy it's good to have you
suzanne how can we help you
good thank you guys so much for taking
my call you got it what's up um
so
this is basically what i've got
so my husband and i we moved up we're
actually in the north idaho area so
we're just kind of over the border from
spokane
we moved here really unexpectedly last
year after my husband lost his job and
it just ended up being such a blessing
he got a job up here
and we absolutely love it
and we don't want to leave we're closer
to family now and he got a good job here
he's been able to start a business so
he's actually working two jobs
and i am a stay-at-home mom now we've
got two baby girls
and
so thank you so it's really expensive
here that's one thing we didn't know we
didn't know the area that well but we
love it so we're determined to stay here
and we were actually able to pay off all
of our debt last month
wow congratulations super exciting
yes so in the midst of covet and babies
and this move and everything we still
manage to pay off our debt so we own our
vehicles all that
and we're in a rental but we've decided
that we want to go ahead and buy even
though this market is really crazy and
it's really expensive here
but we figured since we're debt-free we
can go ahead and pull the trigger and do
it so we're in the middle of purchasing
a place that we found
so you already have a contract out
yes we do we yeah we close here in a
couple weeks okay
yeah
so
it is expensive and we know that you
know we had started with a budget that
was a bit lower and we decided to go
higher because we just we found this
great property and it just seems like a
wonderful place to raise children and
since we're dedicated to staying in the
area we wanted to do it so you've laid
the groundwork to justify not making a
smart decision is that what happened
is am i questioning the decision
yeah you've laid the groundwork
to have possibly made a not great
financial decision it sounds like
there's a lot of emotion behind this of
just excitement about getting in a house
and all this so give us some details
about the the financial aspect
yeah
so we when we first started looking so
we've been looking for months and months
with our realtor
and
we didn't have a super firm budget in
mind but we decided a round before 50
mark was we didn't want to go much over
that we felt we could really afford that
and still be able to save money but in
this market and in this area where we
live what you can get for 450
just doesn't even seem worth it these
aren't even really starter homes they're
not even really fixer-uppers and
we just found that nothing in that price
range
we were willing to go for so we decided
that we wanted to not only do a house
but get some property since we've got
little kids
so we ended up finding something but
it's about a hundred thousand more so
five fifty then we initially started
yeah so now we're in the 550 range and
how much are you guys putting as the
down payment what percent
well we aren't because we're both
veterans so we're going through a va
loan so we aren't actually putting
anything down
okay what's your take home
yeah so we are yeah we are going to
finance the whole thing um
which puts us at about a 2500 a month
mortgage on a 30 year
yes okay yeah suzanne all right what's
your question you're getting us all
fired up i'm getting riled up suzanne
yes how can we know well that's what i
was i don't know if we can help you
you're knee deep in this thing if i'm
you i'm getting out of this thing if
there's still time but you've already
signed a contract so what's your
question
well my question is um
should we focus on
saving money because you know we're in
this we're going to be paying this
mortgage should we be saving money and
focusing on that or should we focus the
extra money that we have every month
towards this mortgage and get it down
you should have focused it before you
ever gotten this contract and had a
healthy down payment on a 15 year
that's what i would feel better about i
don't love this idea of you guys getting
out of debt and then taking on over a
half million dollars on a mortgage and
thinking that they're doing you a favor
by giving you the va loan
and is that not a big part of your
take-home pay
what is your take-home payment it is
um right now we've got several different
sources of income what's the total
here's what's happened suzanne you
have created a universe
that you want to have you want to be in
this area you want your kids in in this
area well our kids need to go ahead and
have this too so you created that as
well
and you've created a
really
fungible flexible dollar amount we just
got a lot of money coming from this
place and that place and this place and
here's what you've done you've created a
cloud
that allows you to a not see very
clearly and not have to see very clearly
which allows you to live in a fantasy
and now you've zeroed down in one of the
if not the hottest real estate markets
of all time
so it takes a teeny tiny correction and
you are underwater in a half million
dollar house
working side jobs that are we kind of
make this
you know it and suddenly this zero down
va loan is a nightmare
because you're underwater
and you can't get out so tell me how
much money you make
how much money comes into the suzanne
and company home
every month
um about
my husband's business is tough we can't
because it's a new business
but about a hundred thousand a year
right now
is that take-home pay or is that gross
yeah
that's take-home
so you're taking home about eight
thousand dollars
right right and your mortgage is going
to be
uh
over
about 31 percent of your take-home pay
is going towards the mortgage and that's
on a 30-year which we never ever ever
recommend we always tell people to do
the 15-year fixed rate but you're here
right but we're here suzanne how old are
you guys
um 35 and 37. okay you've got a lot of
life to live and i want to see you live
it and i don't want to see you drowning
in this giant mortgage payment with
nothing down
uh i've i've just talked to too many
people heard too many stories and they
start out like yours
starry eyed about the housing market and
wanting to get in we want the property
we got to have the yard and the budget's
flexible and we're not putting anything
down
and all of a sudden they can't breathe
and we get calls i'm sure we'll take one
during this show where someone calls in
and says we're in over our head we put
nothing down on this house and we're
drowning
and so if there's time to get out i mean
it's just you sign well you sign the
contract so you sign the contract
i don't know what the situation is there
uh if you're stuck with this thing
you may want to look at increasing
income refinancing to a 15-year and
making sure that you can afford it but
as far as paying down the mortgage i
mean it's a little late for that
conversation
because we're really we're knee-deep in
this thing
but we recommend 10 to 20 down to avoid
pmi or more on a 15 year where the where
the mortgage payment is no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay so so far
every one of the every one of the rules
has been broken which just hurts my
heart because i want to see you guys win
and you've worked so hard to get to this
point where you're debt-free and you're
making these decisions and i don't want
to see you step backwards and make a bad
financial decision for your future but
if you're here to answer your question
yes i would treat
the 20 down as the new gazelle intensity
i wouldn't save money i would sprint and
get some sort of cushion underneath your
feet and make sure you have an emergency
fund of three to six months before you
do any before you start saving anything
right you're under water and y'all got
to get your head above water first get
20 down on that house pay it down and
get an emergency fund